So 2022 was quite the year.
Here's Bloomberg's two-minute round up.
In January,
the Federal Reserve laid
the groundwork to raise rates
to tackle the fastest inflation
in a generation.
Adding to global inflationary pressures:
Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
The attack began in late
February and dominated headlines
from the destruction on the ground
to US sanctions on
Russian banks and oligarchs.
By March, attention
zeroed in on the specific
threats that Russia posed:
restricting the flow of
natural gas to Europe
and attacks near a nuclear power
plant in Ukraine.
Corporate drama started
to pick up in April
when Elon Musk made a $43 billion
offer to take Twitter private.
While Netflix
reported a loss in subscribers
and changed its strategy
to embrace advertising.
The theme in May: market mayhem,
as the Fed boosted the
size of its rate hike
to half a percentage point,
sending US stocks to 13-month lows.
While a single trader at Citigroup
made a mistake
that sparked a flash crash
in European stocks.
Recession fears took root in June.
Half the headlines of Bloomberg's
ten most-read stories
that month featured the R word.
Another R word:
Roe, after the Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade.
Geopolitics were the big
stories over the summer.
The killing of former
Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe
and Nancy Pelosi defying China
when she visited Taiwan.
The UK lost its longest-
serving monarch in September.
Two weeks later,
the new Prime Minister
unveiled unfunded tax cuts
that caused the pound
to crash.
In October,
Credit Suisse became a meme stock
setting new lows as some retail investors
bet the bank would go bust.
While Xi Jinping consolidated
his power, adding more loyalists
to China's leadership.
Crypto winter arrived in November
when FTX collapsed,
destabilizing the industry.
And by December,
bankers were tallying up
the cost from slumping markets
sparked by the Fed's rate-hike campaign.
Their wallets will take
a hit as Wall Street
firms prepare to slash year-end bonuses.